hello everyone and welcome to another
video about the popular neural network
that is Lila chest zero now you might
remember some may be less than a month
ago I made a one video about Lila zero
where I mentioned that at the moment at
the time I was making this video she was
rated about around 1800 and while she's
not at alpha zero level just yet
she is already rated maybe not rated but
she did play a match against and over
3,000 rated engine and she also
performed over 3,000 so what I don't
want to mention a couple of things well
as of I think as of today or maybe maybe
yesterday you can actually play against
Lila just zero unleashes Lila has
Alicia's account here you can find her
as Lila chess there with purple letters
you can see that she is a bot and she
already has 332 followers the way you
challenged her you have to follow her
and then you have to wait for her to
follow you back and only then you can
play against her the reason she has a
leach s account is B is because I'm
Sunday I don't really know the date let
me just check sunday will be a 22nd yeah
Billy 22nd of April she will be playing
a match against the Andrew tank
Grandmaster Andrew tank also known as
the penguin unleashes so that will
definitely be an interesting event and
as of this season
Lila will also be competing in the TCC
event the top chess engine championship
even though she's not an engine
basically she's a neural net but she's
the first neural net that will be
competing in such an elite championship
for engines
she will not be you know battling the
strongest engines right right away like
stock fish and Houdini but first she has
to start in a lower division but as she
improves she will definitely get get a
chance to challenge the big boys so in
the this this year's in the TCC she will
be running on a CPU but maybe as of next
year as the makers of Lee Lash's 0 say
depending on the community and the
contributions they receive as you will
then maybe even run on a GPU or /tp you
next year which of course will make her
a lot more powerful but other than this
Lila also played a match against the LA
so stable avec la so stable avec is an
international master from Norway also a
a law student he's 25 years old and he
play a 10/10 game match against Leela in
rapid time for MIT I will tell you
results of the match after I show you
this game but this is one of the games
we were played and it's quite an
interesting game very very human-like so
I really enjoyed it and I will show you
probably a couple of more games since we
do have to prepare for her big match
with the penguin and another interesting
thing to actually qualify for the TC EC
legal I had to Lilla had to score a
rating over 3000 because you can't
compete in the TCC if you're rated below
3000 so in her first match against
against engine cold Scorpio she lost
that match and she was she got arraying
performance over around 2,700 but
already in the next match
she played against I believe the engines
the name is fruit also rated very high
she scored a rating performance of over
3000 so she qualified for 40 CC so very
exciting times as about a month ago she
was rated around 1,800 so definitely a
nice learning curve so but to reach the
levels of alpha zero of course she needs
she needs hardware as well as well as
you know a lot of support so let's see
this game in this game mr. lovak who is
also on leaches called iam lawless I
will put a link to his account in the
description below you can also add him
challenge him and and so on so in this
game he played before we have Knight to
f6 c4 e6 Knight to c3 and the d5 so the
Queens gambit declined seek after Sundy
5e capture Sun d5 and now Bishop to g5
and this is a the the most standard
position of the Queens gambit declined
I already shown you that game where dodo
tricked his opponent with
Knight B to d7 and and then followed
nice capture Sun d5 and after night
chapters add all those opponent was
extremely confused how did the daughter
overlook his queen about of course after
Bishop captured now comes Bishop to b4
check and it's it is now very
understandable that White's didn't
really win anything as white is down a
whole night here but in the game
Lila played Bishop to e6 we have Queen
to b3 now pressuring the d5 pawn
although you can never really capture
that but going for the b7 point Bishop
to d6 and now you have to decide what to
do here probably the best idea in the in
the spirit of the position is efore here
you can't really go for Bishop captures
and f6 with the idea of winning a pawn
because you run into pretty much sorry
not Queen captures I you run into pretty
much the same idea as before the Bishop
to b4 check wins the game you have to
move then you lose the Queen but in the
game International Master love it play
the Queen capture some b7 and what are
this is the losing move that actually
lost in the game probably not but it's
very interesting how Lila plays against
against this idea Knight B to d7 as the
rock on 8 was attacked III we have rook
to b8 and Queen captures on a 7 so now
white already grabbed both b-pawn and D
a pawn
so if white can castle safely that's
basically a winning advantage you're
just gonna push the a pawn and and win
the game the a pawn is a passed pawn
nothing can oppose it but let's see what
happens here we have castles by Lila and
the Bishop to d3 so you still have to
develop the Bishop tonight and then you
can castle
we have c5 and here Bishop to b5 the
problem here if you want to just start
developing really quickly to get your
King to safety as soon as possible for
example you develop 90 G to e2 then
black will play c4 you have to move the
bishop not the c2 you don't want to
allow rook caps or some b2
with it what a temple on this Bishop on
c2 so after rook captures now if you
castle your run into Bishop captures an
h2 with Czech team captures
then you're gonna lose the game very
quickly as White Queen h4 is coming even
even if white the defense this you can
even give up one night just just the
block this diagonal so after c5 you
can't really go for for some rapid
development unfortunately Bishop to b5
this was tried by international master
Loic rook to e8 Queen to b7 and now C
captures on d4 so you do have to respond
to this ich after 74 and now Queen to a5
and now the knight on c3 is pinned but
even more important this opens up a path
for this rook from f8 to come join join
the attack on the White Queen Bishop
captures on d7 we have now rook F to be
eight so an in-between move that gets
the rook mobilized Quintus e6 and now
Bishop captures on d7 Queen captures on
d6 and Rev character Sam b2 so if you
look at this position Oliva is down a
piece but it's very hard for white to
find a move here
the knight is under attack here so there
really isn't much you can do in the game
white played nice to e2 but there is a
move that pretty much solves everything
for black rook captures on e2 and this
was played in the game you can't capture
with the knight of course the knight is
pinned so King captures and now Queen
captures on c3 and now what do you do
here well you would definitely enjoy
getting your King back to safety
so rook H to be won you might you might
ask yourself why not why not
lukkage the c1 getting your rook into
the game and also attacking the Queen
and not allowing the Queen to give check
on c4 I had the reason is then you allow
Bishop to b5 check
that's why rook to be one was essential
because after Bishop to b5 the King can
no longer run to f1 and after a couple
of a couple of checks white will be
checkmated very very soon here Queen
captures Queen d3 check King here Queen
B 5 and there is now no more
no more running for the White King Queen
a sex rock captures this will be
checkmate
so after Queen captures on c3 rock H the
b1 now not allowing the Bishop to b5
check but it doesn't matter lilo goes
for Queen to c4 check rook King to e1
and now rook to e8 check Bishop to e3
blocking and it's a very nice position
for you to even pause the video and try
to find how to continue the attack here
for black so do try and find it give it
a couple of seconds you know or even a
minute if you feel like it so if you
found the found the move congratulations
you are an excellent attacker and if you
just want to enjoy the show here Lilla
played Bishop to g4 now the threat of
course is Queen to eat to checkmate and
there is very little white can do here
in the game f3 was played but even if
you try something like rook to be - to
prevent checkmate this way then Queen to
c3 ends the game immediately you either
move the King and then Queen captures on
b2 you lose the rook or you block with
the rook and then you get Queen captures
and I want roadblocks and Queen capture
some d1 again with checkmate but okay in
the game f3 was played but now comes
rope captures on d3
this is with check King 2 f2 and now
Queen captures on d4 there are no
threats white can make on the last rank
as this rook will rush back into the
defense with a discover to check so King
back to f1 now Bishop captures on f3
again there is nothing white can do here
Queen to g3 was played now Bishop to e2
check King moves and now Bishop to b5 a
discovered check from the rook and it
was in this position that Norwegian
international master Lassa of stable
logic resigned the game there is of
course nothing you can do if you capture
with the Queen you lose the Queen and
then you're getting checkmated and if
you move the King then simply you move
the rock rocky 4 check King here and
then Bishop to e2 this this will be
checkmate so yeah after this Bishop to
b5 check mr. lovak resigned the game and
a very nice 26 move game we might say a
miniature
was created by allele hs0 so I really
enjoyed this game and I will put a link
in the description below which all of
the games from this match so you're free
to check out all of them all the games
are very interesting and I did mention
that Lila lost the first her first match
against the chess engine were that she
had to play to qualify for the TCC the
engine Scorpio but she achieved also a
very nice miniature with the black
pieces against it so I will try to find
that game to show it to prepare for our
Sunday match hello Lila chess 0 against
against Andruw tank so and yeah a couple
of you did mention that this is not
Leela this is Cortana yeah the reason
I'm using Cortana is that Lila still
does not have any any graphics to her so
I do I don't need to put something here
so since I don't have anything to use as
Leela I decided to use Cortana there's
no specific reason for it I just you
know googled AI and it's one of the
things that popped out I thought it was
thought it was kind of kind of feeling I
don't know well maybe it was a poor
choice but you know I I did do it so
basically there it is everybody yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and like I said I will show a couple of
more games played by Lee latches 0 I
will put a lot of links in the
description below where you can check
out a lot of her games how to play
against her how to install her how to
help her become stronger basically every
useful link about Lee watches 0 will be
in the description below so feel free to
check all of it out I would also like to
think I'll make me more than ever
contributing to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon probably would another game by
Lila chest 0 thank you